they are the images organizers of this
protest had desperately hoped to avoid
but for a second night police officers
under attack from an angry crowd around
whitehall running for cover
as protesters threw bottles and other
objects at them as the officers headed
under the arches in King Charles Street
reinforcements from the Nets Public
Order unit rushed in to hold the police
line at least one officer we saw
suffered a head injury and the violence
as more reinforcements arrived police
began making some arrests before gaining
control and holding off the crowd these
images will deeply worry police
commanders and the Home Secretary
already incensed about the violence here
just a day earlier
I'm absolutely sickened and appalled by
the level of violence that was on
display police officers were abused and
police officers were injured and we have
a police officer that is seriously
injured and in hospital right now and
that is absolutely unacceptable this
will be deeply disappointing for the
many thousands of peaceful demonstrators
who turned up on mice outside the US
Embassy earlier in the day determined
that message one of peaceful protests
would be the abiding image how we
thought after being oppressed for such a
long time so their feeling of anger it
is there so I do understand the but it
is not just two weeks after George Floyd
was killed in Minneapolis the passion
and sense of injustice is still profound
government ministers police and health
officials had arged people to stay at
home because of the ongoing coronavirus
health emergency the huge turnout an act
of defiance from these potestas who said
the issue was just too important to stay
at home
when we walk into a shop when we walk
anywhere else if we'll give our friends
are black they just go press straight
away you can see they get jobs and it's
not fast not how society could be in
harmony as darkness descended on
Whitehall more serious violence as an
angry crowd confronted Public Order
police officers the Prime Minister has
said people have a right to protest
peacefully but they have no right to
attack the police these demonstrations
he said had been subverted by thuggery